hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
made the USS [ __ ] the ocean but what I
did not do is enable myself to be able
to go deeper than how I've been able to
go before and that's because even this
sub can only go to about 225 meters
under water before it starts crushing it
needs upgrades just like the seamoth
needs upgrades so as you can see it was
a little bit confusing and I don't I
don't you know I'm not putting down what
I've done here I've done amazing things
you're making the submarine that
obviously no one has ever managed to
make it's incredible this feat of
engineering that I've been able to do
but I still have a lot of work to do so
what I need to be able to do that I've
looked this up and you guys have told me
well enough I need what's called a moon
pool and a moon pool can this get out of
my face thank you let go back to my kylo
Ren waves or whatever Dark Lord of the
Sith I need to be I need to build but I
do not have the blueprints for a moon
pool and I checked because in my log
that I can't get to right here in my log
or my blueprints I've looked over
everything and I don't have a moon pool
so my understanding is that I need to
it'd be really cool to have a terraform
because I didn't get that blueprint um
it's not the modification station
because I already built that and it's
only for modifying items that I
currently have so I need to go find the
blueprint for the moon pool and I'm
guessing that's just in things that I
need to scan around so what I'm gonna do
is you're gonna see a montage of me
going around being an idiot and crying
to the heavens for the things that I
does not have which is hello which is a
moon pool brutal blueprint and then I'll
get that and then you'll see me come
back with a little bit more intelligence
than what I have right now so off I go
into the
hello goodbye I imagine it's got to be
like far away from where I normally go
which means oh god I am actually I am
actually in a bit of a bother here
because I don't think I do but I don't
have enough water okay so I need to take
these home with me so alright so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to get this
guy I know that's why I'm collecting
sacks of air I know I know I know
Karen leave me alone Karen I love you
Karen
you're my babe my babe oh it's getting
dark oh god I hate it oh the kelp forest
I hate it in the dark every time every
time I load up this game I'm reminded by
how terrifying it is I know what it is
but God
oh hi how's it going there you can't
hurt my seamoth don't even bother get
out of here you broke a tooth you douche
oh you too you want dental replacement
huh don't even think about messing with
me because I'm not thinking about
messing with you I'm not thinking about
anything but my nice warm beau hey come
on
stop being so rowdy everything's gonna
be alright yay unlocked propulsion
cannon I don't okay cool I don't know
what that do but it sounds cool I like
the sound of that
what am I gonna propulse monster of some
sort am i gonna shoot a monster with
another monster oh is it a fish gun
hello
Sancho how you doing Oh have you met my
boys they're up on the surface and I
definitely know the Nick their names and
I'm not stalling for time what are you
talking about I didn't actually see it
from the front oh that is a thing of
beauty it's delightful
Geoffrey Billy samurais and marshal
Geoffrey Billy Sam was Marshall I know
their names I know the names of my
delightful sons Geoffrey Billy's Samwise
Marshall and me their dad bubble butt oh
good it's almost a time ray Oh God
all right I need to figure out where the
hell this is whoa what is that I didn't
even know that was there oh I didn't
know that a side panel I should know Oh
God Power Cell nice nice nice okay off I
go
something worth it now I already have a
modification station I think I gotta go
much farther in another direction maybe
like behind this the crashed ship I've
never gone back there not even true
worth a shot with the chat worth a shot
yeah because the ship is all you know
it's actually a ship it's all there it's
like a physical object in the world you
can see it's like school in the past
it's got to be something know that I was
in this area I'm gonna find this
moonpool I'm gonna get this moon pool
now my baby see Martha's gonna be big
and strong what was that hey who's doing
that
who's taking bites out of us seamoth not
okay okay all right okay oh you're big
Oh what are you
whoa whoa no no no okay so that's why
didn't go around the other side of the
ship Hodge oh damn sorry
Jesus oh my goodness my word what was
that thing it was big it's bigger than
anything I've seen before Oh Frick [ __ ]
is it coming for me oh it's coming for
me is it Oh God
what are you what do you want go away
okay oh my hello okay oh no it's goddamn
seamoth Oh Frick dick make a pic oh god
okay yeah how's the seamoth right
okay I don't think I'm out of the woods
yet
but my seemeth exploded that's nice
Jeffrey Billy and Sam wise and Marshall
sure didn't build that one to standards
this is still around there no hopefully
one of these has a first aid kit I need
some air oh god oh god that's terrifying
warning 30 seconds
thanks Karen I'm actually almost out of
energy for this thing to battery with me
of anything Oh God
I gotta like swim back oh god it's doing
the thing where it started recharge at
the same time
you think I got a knife so if he wants
to tangle again I'm gonna show him the
what for and the who's what okay okay
never mind I didn't say anything about
him well guess I'm on my own now
by myself oh good distilled water
exactly what I needed this situation
right immediately now find a seamoth
that'd be lovely if I could disassemble
it to get the batteries in it I'd be
very happy god something is not happy
over here
well I'm lost and I'm stuck out here in
the middle of nowhere
my only probably hope is to die I mean
literally it's the only option I have so
what better way to die then at the hands
of whatever the hell that thing was
hello hi you want to go mano-a-mano
I've got cured peepers they're nice and
disinfected water you want a go bra huh
I've got a mean face and a pants full of
piss and also there might be a little
poop in there and I'm very scared and
also I know this is a bad idea but hey I
want to get at least one slice in on you
you're gonna see it before you believe
it
I'm dead okay well this is me then I
think it's taking bites in my groin I
should be dead now my dad didn't lots of
stuff well then everything turned out
better than expected who knew that when
you died you just wake up back in your
own base so that whoa that journey went
awry that journey went bad that journey
none do good let me see what the
propulsion cannon is warps gravity to
push and pull that doesn't help me uh I
need to make another CMOS again all
right so that's all for this episode
that went horribly that went wrong no I
was supposed that suit was supposed to
be me about finding the moonpool I don't
even know how to do that I'm gonna go
look up to make sure that the thing is
actually even something that I need to
do so I'll be back later so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
the trick is he let go on those in
actually fall down oh wow I jogged